[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات في العناوين
كيف تطالبوا بمحاسبه
كافه الاطراف للوساطه
الى المصري
في ايران عبر الاقمار الصناعيه لفك حصار
النظام على المتظاهرين
جيش وكوريا الجنوبيه يتعهد بتطوير قدراته
ويعتذر عن فشله في اسقاط مسيره كوريا
الشماليه
ورئيس صربيا يعلن حاله التاهب القصوى
للجيش لاستخدام القوه المسلحه بسبب
التوترات مع كسوفو
اهلا بكم البدايه من الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
كشف وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
عن سماعي عن مساء لاقامه دوليه لانهااء
الحرب في بلاده في غضون شهرين متهم في
تصريحات
روسيا بالتلاعب بقضيه السلامه
ستكون ذات شقين اولها عدم السماح لروسيا
بالتلاعب بقضيه السلام لانهم يقولون
باستمرار انهم مستعدون للمفاوضات وهذا غير
صحيح لان كل ما يفعلونه في ساحه المعركه
يثبت العكس تماما اما الشوط الثاني هو
محاكمه روسيه عن جرائم الحرب
وفي ردين على مبادره كيف مشاهدينا قال
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرا انه لن يتوسط في حل الازمه
الاوكرانيه الا بموافقه جميع الاطراف من
ضمنها روسيا وكانت السلطات الاوكرانيه
اقترحت قبل الان عقد قمه سلام في الامم
المتحده بواسطه الامين العام واشترط تكييف
دعوه روسيا للمفاوضات فقط بعد اجراء
محاكمه جرائم حرب في المحاكم الدوليه
تصعيد من دبلوماسي لافتهم بين موسكو وكيف
اوكرانيا الدول الاعضاء في الامم المتحده
لحرمان روسيا الاتحاديه من وضعها كعضو
دائما في مجلس الامن الدولي واستبعادها
كليا من الامم المتحده مطلب لا فرص له
للنجاح وفقا لمراقبين
تصريحات اوكرانيه يقابلها تهديد ووعيد
روسيا جاء على لسان وزير الخارج
الذي غير المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بين تنفيذ
المقترحات الروسيه بنزع السلاح او ان يحسم
الجيش الروسي الامر وتوعد الوزير لافراف
كيف بطول امد الحرب اوكرانيا اعلنت قبل
ذلك انها تهدف الى عقد قمه السلام بحلول
نهايته فبراير المقبل
وفي اول رد للكريم لن على مقترح كيف قال
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتر
بيسكوف ان موسكو لم تتبع ابدا شروط
الاخرين بل تلتزم فقط باهدافها الخاصه
يعني موسكو تقول بانها لا تتبع شروط
الاخرين كيف تفهم كيف هذا التصريح حذيفه
عن الجانب الاوكراني وتحديدا القياده
والسلطه الاوكرانيه هي يعني لا تنظر الى
همم مثل هذه التصريحات
بعين ب همم جاده هي تتحدث عن شروط واضحه
للسلام تتحدث عن شروط واضحه لانهاء الحرب
طبعا همم وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني يتحدث
عن ان اوكرانيا عازمه على عقد
مفاوضات سلام في بدايه فبراير بعد ان تدخل
الحرب العامه الثاني وهنا كيف تعول على ان
تكون على على وضع القتال على ارض المعركه
يقوله ذلك تقدم للجيش الاوكراني بعد ان
يحصل طبعا على المساعدات والاليات
والاسلحه المطلوبه لذلك في فتره الشتاء
تحاول ان يكون هنالك تقدم واضح للجيش
الاوكراني وهي ايضا تنظر الى تصريحات
الكريم والرئيس قوتي حول همم يعني طلب
مفاوضات السلام والجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات ولكن طبعا هي لديها شروطها
وابتداء
بالانسحاب التام لجيش الاتحاد الروسي من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وان يكون هنالك ضمانات
امنيه للجانب الاوكراني بشكل واضح تكون
هنالك دول ضامنه لذلك هذه الدول يكون
لديها حق التدخل في حاله ما كان هنالك
هجوم على اوكراسي وكامله الاتحاد الروسي
او من دول اخرى ايضا ان يكون الجانب
الاوكراني قادر على الحصول على الاسلحه
فورا في حاله حدوث اي هجوم على الدوله
الاوكرانيه هي بالمقابل تقدم ان تكون دوله
اا محايده لا تكون جزءا من اي صراع في
اتجاه في الاتحاد الروسي هذه هي الضمانات
الاساسيه والبنود الاساسيه التي يعتمد
عليها تعتمد عليها اكيد طبعا ايضا كيف
الان تجري بعد الجهود داخل وقت الامم
المتحده للوصول الى عمليه اقصاء وعزله
لدوله روسيا ادي الاتحاديه هي تعتمد طبعا
على هذا المسمى روسيا الاتحاديه والذي هو
غير موجود في
الماده الثالثه والعشرين والتي تدرس على
قائمه الدول ال- ال- الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده طبعا همم تقول انه من ناحيه
قانونيه من نشاط النظر قانونيه لا يوجد
هذا الاسم روسيا الاتحاديه وهذا طموح
لبوتي ان يكون ذلك اتحاد روسي وانما هنالك
دوله روسيا هذا من جانب ايضا طبعا هي
تعتمد على الفقره همم الرابعه من همم
الفقره الاولى من الماده الرابعه حول ان
الدول الاعضاء في الامم المتحده يجب ان
تكون دول محبه للسلام وهي تعتبر روسيا
دوله تدعو الى الحرب لذلك هي تفقد اهليتها
ان تكون عضوا في الامم المتحده المعلومات
ومن موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمها
تنضم الينا اهلا بك كاتيا كيف تتناول
موسكو تصريحات
زلينسكي ومطالبات اوكرانيا باستبعاد ااه
روسيا تماما من الامم المتحده
مرحبا بك
حتى الان لم ترد على هذه الفصيحات حول سحب
او طرد روسيا من
الامم المتحده لان روسيا بالاساسيه عضو
اساسي في هذه المنظمه روسيا لطالما كانت
كما على اللسان مسؤلها تعتبر انها او
تحترم القانون الامني سواء كان في على
الصعيد الان من همم الطلباتها حول
المطالبات حول حول اوكرانيا هذا من جانب
ومن جانب اخر حول تصريحات زر يمكن او وزير
خارجيه
التي زادت حول المحادثات طبعا كنا قد
شاهدنا زياده في المحادثات من الجانبين
الروسي عفوا زياده بالحديث عن همم امكانيه
حدوث المحادثات بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني سواء كان من جانب الروسي او من
جانب الاخراني والان كنا قد شاهدنا ايضا
تصريحات لانها المتحده حول انها مستعد ل
همم تنظيم
بتاعه ما بين الجانبين في حاله كان
الجانبين طبعا موافقين ولكن لا يوجد حتى
الان اي شيء يبشر بالخير من هذه التصريحات
لان جانبان هم همم هناك تعمد في الموقف
يعني اجانب الروسي هو حتى الان لن يتنازل
عن جميع المطالبات التي بالاساس هو همم
بدا هذه العمليه العسكريه من اجلها وهي
طبعا الحصول على ضمانات امنيه له حول عدم
توسع الناس الى الشرق همم الاتحاد
الاوروبي وايضا همم لن يتنازل عن دم همم
كيف تتناول موسكو او كيف تتفاعل مع
مطالبات قمه السلام في فبراير المقبل
خصوصا وان الرد كان بان روسيا لن تتنازل
او لا تتبع شروط اي احد
صحيح هناك تعمد بالموقف لن يكون هناك
تنازل من الجانب الروسي كما تحدث الرئيس
الروسي بنفسه النزاهه ان روسيا ستذهب
بالعمليه العسكريه حتى النهايه حتى
الحصول على جميع المطالبات الروسيه
بانهاء او عدم وجود اسلحه نوويه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وعدم سماح لانها بتوسع
شرقا وضمانات التي كانت طلبت فيها روسيا
روسيا كان قد بدات هذه المحادثات شهدنا
المحادثات جرت على الاراضي الفيلا روسيه
وتركيا ولكن كما تقول ان الشرف الامريكي
الذي هو بالاساس لديه مصلحه في اطاله هذه
العمليه العسكريه بتزويده المستمر
همم
بالاسلحه لا يوجد شيء يبشر بالخير لان
روسيا هي ستقف على جميع شروط التي وضعتها
منه الاساس للدخول في هذه المفاوضات التي
طبعا يرفضها اجانب الاخراني
ماذا كان يقصد
حين اصرح بان موسكو ستحسم الامر على الارض
الجيش الروسي سيحسم الامر ماذا يعني بذلك
هل هناك بوادر عن ما قصده بذلك
همم حتى الان الاعمال العسكريه كما نشهد
هي جاري على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وان الارض
ما سيحدث على الارض هو الذي سيحسم الموقف
كما اتحدث الوزير الخارجيه الروسي سر هي
الابراج فما ستحسم او سيحسن الجيش الروسي
الموقف على الارض بعد ان يسيطر على جميع
الاراضي التي هي ضمن همم الخطه الروسيه
بالاضافه الحفاظ على الاراضي التي ضمتها
مسبقا روسيا وهو شبه جزيره الكرم هذا ما
يحسم الموقف كما تحدث وزير الخارجيه
الروسي وبالتالي عندها يمكن الذهاب الى
طاوله المحادثات كما يعتبر هو موقف قوي
بعد حسم جيش الروسي الموقف على الاراضي
الروسيه وتدمير جميع الاسلحه التي تحصل
عليها اوكرانيا سنشهد بعد فتره دخول
منظومه الفتره الى همم القوات الاوكرانيه
وهذا معتبر هو الرئيس الروسي انه من السهل
همم القضاء على هذه المواد لان روسيا
لديها جميع المعلومات النقاب ضعف هذه
المنظومه فاطمه شكرا لك من موسكو مراسله
العربيه كاتيا طعمه
في سياق اخر وصف وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجي لافروف تصريحات مسؤولين امريكين من
البنتاجون حول توجيه ضربه قطع الراس الى
الكرملين بانها تهديد بالتصفيه الجسديه ضد
الرئيس الروسي واضاف لابروف في تصريحات
نيوكالات تاس ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
عليهم التفكير مليا في العواقب المحتمله
لمثل هذه التصريحات واشار لا ظروف الى ان
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي تخطى الحدود بمطالبه دول
الناتو بتوجيه ضربات نوويه وقائيه الى
روسيا في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديميتر كوليبا ان بلاده ستفعل
بوسعها ليكون عام 20 23 هو عام انتصار
لاوكرانيا مؤكدا في تصريحات بريس ان
اوكرانيا لن تتنازل عن وحدها
سنفعل كل ما في وسع نار العام المقبل من
النصر الاوكراني وهذا الانتصار يعني
الاستعاده الكامله لوحده اراضي اوكرانيا
لن نتفاوضا على اي مربع او سنتيمتر من
ارضنا هذا ابعد من المفاوضات
الحكومه التونسيه تقول انه لا بديل عن قرض
صندوق النقد واتحاد الشغل يهدد باحتلال
الشوارع
حياكم الله من جديد بعد توقيع الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد قانون الميزانيه لسنه
20-23 قالت وزيره الماليه التونسيه سهام
البغدادي انه لم يكن من السهل انجاز
القانون وطبعا ذلك مشاهدينا بسبب صعوبات
عده في ظل ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه تعيشها
البلاد وشددت على ضروره الحصول على قرض من
صندوق النقد الدولي من جهه الثانيه اكد من
العام للاتحاد التونسي للشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي انا الاتحاد سينظم احتجاجات
وسيحتل الشوارع قريبا وذلك لاظهار الرفض
للميزانيه التقشف للعام المقبل على حد
وصفه
كاعاده على الشاشه وقال ان شركه هو لخدمه
الانترنت عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
محطه ارضيه لخدمات الانترنت في ايران وذلك
لمساعده المحتاجين في ظل المحاولات النظام
حجم خدمات الانترنت في البلاد الانترنت
هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس شركه سبيس اكس
الملياردير الامريكي الى المعسكر تصريح
وماسك جاء كار الدين على تغريده لاحد
المستخدمين في تويتر نشر فيها مقطع فيديو
قال انه التقط في شوارع ايران معتبرا انه
الان توجد حريه اكبر للنساء في اختيار ما
اذا كنا يردن تغطيه شعرهن ام لا اعلان
ماسك عن المئه جهاز التي تعمل بالفعل في
ايران تاتيك بالوعد كان قطعه في سبتمبر
الماضي اذا اعلن حينها انه سيعمل على
اتاحه الانترنت عبر شبكته للاقمار
الصناعيه في ايران في وقت تفرض فيه
السلطات المزيد من القيود على الانترنت
لمنع ايصال صوت المتظاهرين الى الخارج
وستعمل خدمه نطاق العريض المعتمده على
الاقمار الصناعيه في مساعده الايرانيين في
الالتفات على قيود حكومه المفروضه للوصول
الى الانترنت وبعض منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي ووسط الاحتجاجات وهو ما سيكل
مصدر ضغط جديد على النظام الايراني
عادل الغامدي الباحث في تقنيه وامن
المعلومات اهلا بك معنا سيد عادل كيف
يستطيع او يستطيع ستورلينج وانا اسال
تقنيه كيف تستطيع على مساعده المحتاجين او
فك الحصار عن المحتجين في ايران
اهلا وسهلا نهارك سعيد اول شيء لازم نفهم
كيف تلعب كيف تعمل همم شبكه ستايلنج
سكارليت اللي بتعمله انه عمليه الدش عادي
زي اللي بيركب في البيت همم حجمه تقريبا
اقل من نصف متر بيركب في اي مكان وبنحط
عليه جهاز راوتر وبتوسع على الانترنت
وانتهى الموضوع واشتراك 99$ همم ممكن
ادخالها اتصال فضائي اجهزه استقبال فضائي
اللي في المنازل كل بيت تقريبا عنده جهاز
استقبال فضائي فانت اللي هتدخل على الدوله
انت قاعد تدخل جهاز همم استقبال فضائي
بيدخل الجهاز وبتمنى الناس تستخدمه همم
حتى الان حتى هذه اللحظه حسب موقعها محطوط
انه ايران خارج التغطيه همم بس بما انه
يقول انه هي دخل تغطيه فهو اكيد عملها همم
افضل اغلب هتكون عن طريق التحرير زي ما كل
الدول
على الشبكه داخليه وتعمل توزيع الانترنت
على المواطن خروج ما هتكون على منطقه
كاشامله كبيره جدا والجهاز اللي هيكون
موجود حيطه المنطقه له موجود فيها بالضبط
استقبال ارضيه المتواجده حاليا لا تحتاج
الى اجهزه استقبال خاصه
همم
الجهاز العادي ما ممكن استخدامه هي
الاقمار الصناعيه
يمكنك محطه ارضيه بترسل القمر الصناعي
القمر الصناعي بيعكسها على منطقه ثانيه في
الارض وتستقبلها همم الانترنت بترسل من
مكان ما حول العالم في ال- همم الخاص همم
اي اس بي انت نسيت بروفايدر همم ممكن من
امريكا ممكن من اي مكان عشان تطلع امريكا
تطلع انت داخل الدوله
انت طلعت من الثلاثه لكن انه اي دوش فضائي
عادي لا يمكن استخدام اي دوش لازم جهاز
خاص يتم توجعه على الاجهزه الخاصه على
الاقمار الصناعيه لما يجي واحد بثبت قديش
عنده في البيت بيقول لك انت تبغى النايل
سات ولا العرب الخاصه
26 هذه السيد عادل ما مدى سهوله اختراقها
او ايقافها من قبل النظام الايراني
الموقع الجهاز صعب جدا لكن الاجهزه هذه
متاثره بعوامل الجويه لازم استمر تكون
صافيه هي حتى الانترنت
صناعيه الخاصه بالانترنت تكون على
مستوى منخفض تقريبا على 400 كيلو فقط سطح
البحر لكن اذا كان الاجواء غير صافيه على
اجواء مغيمه امطار هذه كلها بتاثر على جثه
الانترنت لكن عمليه اختراق ما اعتقد هتكون
بهذه السهوله ان كان عرفت الموقع الجهاز
وتم صادته طيب ما ان همم حضرتك تقول سيد
عادل بان ايران خارج تغطيه هذا القمر او
ستور لان كما ان صحت اقوال انه ماسكه
بالفعل وصل الى تغطيه ايران ما مدى الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تشكل فارق في الاحتجاجات وفي
سهوله وصول المحتجين
للعالم الخارجي
موضوع ايران والانترنت ترى موضوع طويل جدا
حد من ايام باراك اوباما حتى لما حصل
حصاركم قبل كده في السابق طلعوا انه بنرفع
حلول انترنت بنفتح حلول التوفير لدعم
ايران
للمواطنين فحصول الانترنت الانترنت قضايا
موجود في اغلب الدول العالم همم في بعض
الدول اللي حاطه عليها الاستركشن يعني انت
لو تفتح نفس الموقع الاسترلينج بتشوف
المواقع العالم بيحط لك كل الدوله
الصلاحيه من الدوله همم انتظار صلاحيه
الدوله عشان بتخش انظمه الفواتير وفي
انظمه السداد في انظمه الدفعات انظمه
الصلاحيات لكن انه انا اغطي همم الدوله
بطريقه معينه كائنا ماسك كاستثناء ممكن
جدا همم بتم تغطيها عن طريق هو عنده
تقريبا قربت 3000 قمر صناعي يدور حول
الارض همم
ممكن ما حطها همم
خبر رسمي على الموقع لكن هو اعلنها انه
هيكون بالضغط تمبر وبالفعل الان تمطر يعني
شكرا لك من جد عادل الغامدي الباحث في
تقنيه المعلومات
المرصد السوري افاد بمقتل ثلاثه من عناصر
المخابرات العسكريه السوريه واصابه اخرين
في هجوم شانه مسلحون مجهولون في درعا وقال
المرصد ان الهجوم استهدف حاجزا امنيا في
بلده النعيم وشرق درعا مضيفا ان اشتباكات
وقعت بين الجانبين عقب هذا الهجوم واشار
ايضا الى ان المسلحين تمكنوا من الفرار
الى جهه مجهوله القيادين في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قال ان هناك عمليات تمشيط
متواصله بعد هجوم لداعش على مقره امنيه
بينها سجن في شمال سوريا
وفي لقاء مع العربيه اضافه القيادي في قصه
ان داعش يستغل العمليات التركيه ضدهم لشني
عملياته
تم قتل احد العناصر المهاجمه وايضا تم
اعتقال احدهم يلبس حزام ناسف
وفيما فر ال بقيه ال ال الخليه الى
الاحياء المجاوره وبدات بعدها عمليه تنشيط
واسعه وما زالت مستمره عمليه التمشيط كل
ما تزداد تهديدات تركيا لمناطقنا كلما
ازداد نشاط الخلايا الارهابيه
نبقى في سوريا حيث يمثل فصل الشتاء معاناه
متفاقمه للنازحين السوريين الاف نازحين من
مدينه اعزاز من اهالي مدينه عفرين بعد
سيطره فصائل المسلحه مواليه لتركيا على
المدينه في عام 2018 يعانون من اوضاع
انسانيه كارثيه ويطالبون المجتمع الدولي
باغاثتهم
من صمت الركام تخرج الحياه في الشمال
السوري هنا حين يسرد الصمت لحظات فزع
النازحين السوريين وهم يواجهون اللام فر
بين نيران القصف التركي وطرق مسدوده
بحواجز النظام السوري
في مدينه اعزاز لا تجدوا سوا فراغ يحاول
ملئه سكان ونازحوا المدينه هنا منازل
ناجيه من حرب فرضت نفسها منذ سنوات
واستقرت الى اجل غير معلوم
بمقابلها بيوت يصلحها اصحابها علها
تستقبلهم من جديد كل شيء بحساب في المدينه
المحاصره بالقصف والحواجز الطعام والمياه
كل شيء يستخدم ضمن حساب يوجد اصحابه ويضعف
من ضيق الحياه
موضوع ما في مواضع اساسيه ما في حتى الخبز
مافي وكاي حرب تستمر للسنوات تتلاشى امال
الصغار وتنحني ظهور عجائزها اكثر في مدينه
اعزاز يعرف الاطفال قيمه فروع الشجر
المتلبسه فنيرانها هي المنقذه من لفحات
البرد
سوء الاحوال الماشيه في الشمال السوري لم
يمنع اكثر من 81% من اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين
الف ناجح سوري وفق بيانات دوليه من اللجوء
الى محافظتي حلب وادلب فهي على سوريا
احوالها يبدو انها تبقى افضل حالا او
بالاحرى اقل سوءا من مناطقهم حنان المصري
العربيه
من سوريا الى فرنسا حيث نظمت الجاليه
الكرديه تظاهرات في باريس للمطالبه
باعتبار الهجوم على المركز الثقافي الكردي
عمليه اغتيال سياسي واعترف منفذ الهجوم
بكراهيتهم المرضيه للاجانب معربا عن اسفه
انه لم يقتل عددا اكبر من الاكراد اثناء
الهجوم
نظمه الاكراد في باريس بعد هجوم يوم
الجمعه لكن الاشتياق لم يتحول الى فوضى
على غرار تظاهره يوم السبت فغابت شعاره
السياسيه ضد تركيا واعلام العمال
الكردستاني لكن شيئا وحيدا لم يتغير هو
مطالبه المتظاهرين السلطات الفرنسيه
بالاقرار بالطبيعه السياسيه للهجوم وخصوصا
ان المتهم بالاعتداء يواجه تهمتي القتل
ومحاوله القتل على اساس انه عنصري وفق
مصدر قضائي فرنسي كشف ايضا ان المشتبه به
بالاعتداء الدامي سائق قطار متقاعد يحمل
جنسيه الفرنسيه واقر باعترافات صادمه
بينها رغبته عدد اكبر اضافه الى انه يكن
كراهيه مرضيه للاجانب
الرجل قرر قتل الاكراد واتى الاستهداف
المركز الديمقراطي الكردي الذي اتهمه
اردوغان وحشيته بانه مركز غير قانوني
لمنظمه غير قانونيه
فرنسي في حمايه اماكن كوردي حساسه تقول
بيرفين السيد الكرديه الاشهر في فرنسا
اليوم ان ذلك لم يتغير برغم الاعتداء
الدامي
لكن على اي حال نحن نتلقى التهديدات عبر
البريد الالكتروني والرسائل النصيه على
هواتفنا ليس تقليلا من هول المصيبه
بالافتقادها عناصر وادله تنفي فرنسا حتى
الان وجود ارتباطات لمنفذ العمليه مع
السلطات التركيه محاوله ربما لعدم صب
الزيت على علاقات متعثره لا ترغب باريس
بزياده نار مع انقره التي استدعت السفيره
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على ما اسمك بالدعايه
السوداء ضد تركيا وهو
انتظار ما ستؤول اليه التحقيقات فادي دهوك
العربيه باريس
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يتراس اجتماعا للحزب
الحاكم لبحث التحديات امام بيونغ يونغ
كيف تطالب بمحاسبه
كافه الاطراف للوساطه
يعلن توفير الانترنت في ايران عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه لفك حصار النظام على المتظاهرين
جيش كوريا الجنوبيه يتعهد بتطوير قدراته
ويعتذر عن فشله في اسقاط مسيرات كوريا
الشماليه
رئيس صربيا يعلن حاله التاهب القصوى للجيش
لاستخدام القوه المسلحه بسبب التوترات مع
كسوفو
حياكم الله من جديد زعيم كوريا الشماليه
مشاهدينا الدعاء الى بذل مزيد من الجهود
للتغلب على المصاعب والتحديات التي
تواجهها بلاده جاء ذلك خلال افتتاحه اعمال
الاجتماع السنوي الرئيسي لحزب العمال
الحاكم بعد اجراء عدد قياسي من التجارب
الصاروخيه هذا العام وذكرت وكاله الانباء
المركزيه ان كم شدد على الحاجه لوضع
استراتيجيات الاكثر اثاره وثقه على اساس
التقدم الذي حققته بلاده في المقابل قدمت
وزاره الدفاع في كوريا الجنوبيه اعتذار
قواتها في التصدي للطائرات المسيره التي
اطلقتها كوريا الشماليه واخترقت المجال
الجويه للعاصمه سول وقالت الوزاره في بيان
انها ستعملوا على تطوير قدرتها المضاده
للطائرات للطائرات المسيره طبعا وذلك في
اقرب وقت
قناه
شاهد للتو مدى خطوره ان تعتمد سياسه كوريا
الشماليه فقط على حسن النيه والاتفاقات
العسكريه التي كانت القوه الدافعه لحادثه
الامس سنسرع خطه انشاء وحده طائره بدون
طيار في اقرب وقت ممكن ثم سنعجز قدرتها
على المراقبه والاستطلاع بطائرات بدون
طيار متطوره قادره على التخفي عن
الرادارات
اهلا الرئيس قصر بيه حاله التاهب القصوى
للجيش بسبب التوترات مع كسوفو الرئيس
فوتشيتشيق امر الجيش ان يكون في اعلى
مستوى للجاهزيه لاستخدام القوه المسلحه
كما اعلن رئيس الاركان الصربي ان رئيس
امره بالتوجه الى المنطقه الحدوديه مع
كوسوفو وفي بيان اصدرته وزاره الدفاع
الصربيا امر رئيس الجمهوريه بزياده عدد
العسكري بالمنتشرين على طول الحدود من
1500 حاليا الى خمسه الاف عسكري
جهدنا وسنحرص على حفظ السلام والاستقرار
ليس ذلك فحسب بل سنعمل على حمايه شعبنا في
شمال كوسوفو وميته هي بعد تسليح الالباني
كوسوفو ورفع استعدادهم القتاليه ساتخذ
جميع الاجراءات الضروريه لحمايه شعبنا
وحمايه صربيا
وفقا لاوامر الرئيس صربيا والقائد العام
لجيش صربيا امرت بالاستعداد القتاليه
الكامل لجميع وحدات وزاره الداخليه
الصربيه وقوات الدرك والوحدات الخاصه
لمكافحه الارهاب واللويه الشرطه
وسيضعون انفسهم على الفور تحت قياده قائد
الجيش وسيحتلون المواقع الموضوع في خطتنا
العملياتيه
هل انتهى العصر الذهبي لشركات التكنولوجيا
اغلب الشركات التي ظهرت خلال الجائحه
تواجهه اليوم تحديات كبيره وذلك بسبب خليه
من العوامل ما دفعها للاستغناء عن عشرات
الالاف من الموظفين في هذا العام الجاري
اعلانات وتسريح بدات مطلع السنه وجاءت
اولا من شركه صغيره ومتوسطه ولكن موجه
التسريح الان طلت عمالقه التكنولوجيا مثل
متى وامازون واوبر
سوفت لدرجه انه تم تاسيس موقع الكتروني
ليفز دوت اف واي يرصد كل الوظائف المفقوده
التي تجاوز عددها 150 الف وظيفه هذه السنه
ورغم ان لكل شركه اسبابها الخاصه الى ان
هناك عوامل مشتركه على القطاع اولا العديد
من تلك الشركات عينت الاف الموظفين خلال
الجائحه استجابه لطلب المتزايد على
خدماتها واملتا بان يدوم اسلوب المعيشه
الرقميه مات مثلا عينت اكثر من 15 الف
موظفا في اول تسعه شهور من السنه الجاريه
ولكن قبل اسابيع اعلن مرض ذكر
انه سيسرح احد عشر الف موظفا اي 13% من
القوى العامله
امازون بدورها اعلنت الاستغناء عن 10,000
موظفا في اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخها
ان تواجهها الواقع فهم واجهوا عده فصول من
تراجع الارادات والكليه تساءل ماذا ستفعل
الشركه لتعامل مع الاداء الصعب والتحديات
والنتائج المخيبه ولكن ايضا ماذا ستفعل
استعدادا لسنه القادمه التي ستكون صعبه
والعديد من الشركات اخذت خطوات للتسريح
منها تويتر وامازون ومجتمع المستثمرين
يودوا ان تكون الشركات اكثر انضباطا
وتشوفا
عامل الاخر وهو اجمل تكلفه المعيشه
وارتفاع معدل التضخم هذا بدوله ادى الى
تراجع الاعلانات عبر الانترنت والمنصات
الرقميه كما ان بعض تغيرات في قواعد
الخصوصيه لدى شركه مثل ابل ضربت سوق
الاعلانات وفي مجال التكنولوجيا الخدمه
الماليه طلقت الشركات ايضا ضربه من ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده
المستثمرون ايضا زاد من ضغطهم على الشركات
لخفض تكاليفها
قامت العديد من هذه الشركات بالاستثمار
للنمو على المدى الطويل ولم تهتم بالربحيه
اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه انتهتماما ويجب
على الشركات اعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والتركيز على المشروعات والمبادرات الاهم
فقط والعمل لنمو اعمالها وتحسين الاداء
الماليه لان المستثمرين لن يصبر 10 سنوات
كي يرون نتيجه الاستثمارات يجب ان يتخذوا
القرارات الصعبه
الى مصر الذي فصل نصف موظفي تويتر هو من
انصار ضروره خفض التكاليف في شركته
الجديده التي تواجه تحديات في زياده
ارباحها واضافه مستخدم جدد كما يرى البعض
ان رواتب ومزايا الموظفين في القطاع
التكنولوجي غير مستدامه واعلى من غيرها من
القطاعات
على المستثمرين في مجال التكنولوجيا
الاجابه تعتمد على حجم وطبيعه الشركه اذا
كان التسريح مجرد خطوه اخرى في طريقه
انهيار الشركه فمثل هذه الاخبار التي تعيد
الثقل المستثمرين ولكن اذا كان الهدف من
التسريح خفض التكليف فهذا قد يكون مرحب به
من قبل المستثمرين لانه قلت يؤدي الى تحسن
الربحيه لندن
شكل الاحتفال بتدشين الملا الاول لسد
جوليوس نيريري في تنزانيا اهتماما كبيرا
في الشارع المصري فالسد تم تشيده من خلال
تحالف لشركات مصريه ويمثل عوده مصريه
للساحات الافريقيه بعد عقود من الغياب
[موسيقى]
الاول
نجاح وتحالف الشركات المصريه في بناء السد
في الوقت المحدد دون اي اخفاقات او تاخير
يراه البعض رساله سياسيه تجسد لعوده مصر
للقاره الافريقيه بعد عقود من الغياب مصر
الاتحاد الافريقي واهتمامها في اطار
التكامل في ما بين مصر وشقها الافريقه لا
غنى عنه احنا دلوقت شغالين مع الشركات
المصريه اللي لها تواجد في عمق القاره
الافريقيه عشان التغلب على بعض الصعوبات
اللي من اهمها ايجاد التموين في حاله
ايجاد تمويل من المؤسسات الماليه الوطنيه
في الدوله المصريه هيكون من السهل اختراق
سوق الافريقي في مشروعات مثيره ومشروعات
كثيره ان شاء الله ترى القاهره ان السد
التنزاني يمثل نموذج لامكا التعاون في
الاطار الافريقيه في مجالات التنميه دون
المسافه بحقوق الدول الاخرى في اشاره
للخلاف بين مصر والسودان من جهه وبين
اثيوبيا من جهه اخرى بشان سد النهضه
الرساله الاساسيه لاثيوبيا والعالم
وافريقيا هي ان مصر لا تقف عائقا ضد
مشروعات التنميه في افريقيا طالما انها لا
تخالف القواعد القانون الدولي ولا تضر
بمصالح مصر واا السودان كما يحدث في سد
النهضه طالما انه لم يحدث هناك اتفاق ومن
المتوقع ان يولد سده ريري
215 ميجا وات خلال عام بعد اكتمال الملك
طاقه تكفي لتوفير الكهرباء للكثير من
المناطق في تنزانيا فيما يرى اخرون ان
انشاء سدود اخرى قد يوفر فائده من
الكهرباء لتصديره لدول الاخرى في شرق
افريقيا مشهد فان تحقق فانه قد يفرض
معادلات سياسيه واقتصاديه جديده في القاره
احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
نهر واحد واجيال متعدده ابن واب وجد
يتعاقبون على خيرات نهر ابي رقراق في
المغرب عبر قارب بدات حكايته مع عائله
اليدين في الرباط نتابع التفاصيل
نهر يقع في غرب المغرب يفصل بين ضفتيه
الرباط وسلا وهو الحد بين زقاق المدينه
القديمه
والتطور الذي تشهده العاصمه المغربيه
الرباط
نهر ابي الرقراق والذي ترتبط به البنايات
والحكايات
وبالتاكيد الاشخاص هنا محمد الياديني صاحب
الثلاث 53 عاما مالك هذا القارب الصغير
والذي ترعرع على تجديفه توارثها من والده
وجده والذين كانوا ولا يزالوا يعتاشون من
خيرات هذا النهر
[موسيقى]
تلك القوارب الخشبيه تعاملك وسيله مواصلات
مهمه للراغبين في تجنب حركه المرور
وللذين يعيشون في مكان قريب للبلده
القديمه كما تعد الوسيله الاسهل لوصول
الساكنين بالقرب من النهر لمنازلهم اكثر
من سبع سنين ولا سنين
محمد وجه رساله مهمه بضروره االه اهتمام
اكثر بهذا النهر والذي وصف قاعه بانه مليء
بالكوارث البيئيه والتي اشتكى اصحاب
المنازل المجاوره له من اصول الروائح
الكريهه الى منازلهم محمد السيف العربيه
لدعم ولايه نيويورك التي تضررت اكثر من
ولايه اخرى من العاصفه الثلجيه والتي
ارتفعت حصيلتها في مختلف الولايات
الامريكيه الى 50 قتيلا على الاقل
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تواجه وعواصف الثلجيه
وصفها خبراء الارصاد الجويه بالاقصى منذ
عقود في دليل على الظواهر المناخيه
المتطرفه في العقود الاخيره عاصفه الثلجيه
اسفرت حتى الساعه عن سقوط عدد كبير من
الضحايا اضافه الى خسائر ماديه كبيره
وتعطل مظاهر الحياه في اكثر من منطقه
وولايه مسؤولون في منطقه
نيويورك اكدوا مقتل العشرات في حصيله
اوليه بسبب العاصفه التي شلت ايضا مناطق
غرب نيويورك خلال العطله عيد الميلاد
اذا كانت الحياه بسبب الثلوج التي صنفتها
سلطات نيويورك بالعنيفه والتي تضرب بافالو
ثاني اكبر مدن الولايه منذ اكثر من اربعه
عقود
لقد اكد لي كبير الموظفين في اداره رئيس
بيدن بانه هو خلال فتره بسيطه سيتم
الاستجابه لطلب الاغاثه هذه الاخبار
ستشجعنا على حصر الاضرار لهذه العاصفه
التي يمكن ان نراها مره واحده في حياتنا
في الولايات الامريكيه وتعرضها للعواصف
الثلجيه تكثف هيئه الارصاد الجويه حملات
توعيه لتحذير الامريكيين من خطوره السفر
او التنقل بين المناطق التي تشهد عواصف
ثلجيه مع التشديد على ضروره طلب المساعده
في حال الضروره الملححه للسفر
من اجواء الاعواصف والثلوج الى اجواء راس
السنه واعياد الميلاد تعيش مدينه موسكو
وكيف هذا العام اجواء اعياد ميلاد وراء
السنه ضمن ظروف خاصه تبعا لوضع النزاع بين
البلدين وقعوا الحرب القبض لاله على اجواء
الاحتفالات وزينه المدن بالرغم من
المفارقه الكبيره التي تعكس الظروف
المعيشيه للشعبين الروسي والاوكراني
مراسيلنا عبد الجواد الرشد وحذيفه عادل
يقول لنا واقع الاعياد والاحتفالات بين
موسكو وكيف
هكذا يبدو مركز مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعدي الميلادي وراس السنه في وقت
تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهر هل العاشره انه
كان يشتغل وقال حربي محزن للغايه اول شيء
واقع ومتكرر في الحياه التاريخ يعيد نفسه
ولا يمكن للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه فها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه الصوفيه تقف
مزينه تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل
بالوقود وفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوال
العلم الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد
رمز الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلجين الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عن ظروف الحرب
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه لكن على اي حال
يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد الميلاد لان
شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات يريدون ان
يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمالك مفارقه كبيره
الزينه والاضواء تملان كل ارجاء المدينه
لاعاده البهجه والفرح للمواطن الروسي في
ظل الاوضاع الراهنه خاصه ان الشريط
الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله توتر وسقوط
عشرات الصواريخ يوميا
الذين يعتبرون اهلنا لكل روسي اقرباء في
اوكرانيا ونحن شعب واحد وهذه حقيقه
للاستسلام تبحث عن ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها
اعياد الميلاد في المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام
الاختراع لذا ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه
الفكره فماشيا مع وضع العظام الطاقه ده
دراجه رياضيه تحول الطاقه الحركيه الى
كهرباء
شجره الميلاديه التي تزين صاله الركاب
انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره بلادنا الحره
المستقله
تعتبر مناسبه حميمه لاجتماع الاسره حتى ان
البعض يطلق عليها تسميه العيد العائلي عدد
من الشباب يحتفل بغصه في الحلق هذه السنه
بعيدا عن جو العائله هرب من التعبئه
والعديد من العائلات الروسيه تستقبل عمها
الجديد خارج ديارهم التي لا طالما زقزقت
فيها شمعه راس السنه الجديده ورقصوا على
انغامي تمنياتي من حبي والسلام وبعدين
كانت شوارعها سابقا ترقص وتغني بزينه
العيد ويختلط ليلها بنارها بمشهد الرائعه
هذه هي كيف تقابل اعياد الميلاد والاسر
والاكرانيه في حاله من الشتات فالنساء
والاطفال يغادروا بلادهم والرجال منتشرون
على الجبهات والباقونه يواجهون اوضاع
الانسانيه كارثه ولسان حالهم يقول باي حال
عدت يا عيد
انا الان موعد اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميله
فاطمه
عيد انا مشاهدينا دعونا نفاصل حركه
الاسواق المنطقه وايضا الاسواق العالميه
مؤشر سوق الاسهم السعوديه يسجل ارتفاع
يتمكن من كسر حاجز ال 10,300 نقطه صعودا
في هذه اللحظات بعد ما كان متماسك طيله
هذا الاسبوع عن مستويات النقطه وايضا مع
استمرار ضعف السيوله بشكل كبير كما ذكرنا
يوم امس بالكافه حددنا عن مليار و900
مليون ريال سيف غاليري السهم رقم 16 الذي
ينضم الى سوق الاسهم السعوديه في عام 2022
والبدايه ليست ايجابيه سعر الادراج كان
عند ال 15 السهم يتداول عند ال 162 مع
الرغم من الشركه اوسط بتوزيع ارباح نقديه
عن الربع الثالث ب 10% او مقابل الريال عن
الربع الثالث ما عدا ذلك اسواق المنطقه
متباينه لازلنا نتحدث عن النطاق ضيق احجام
تداول ضعيفه ونحن نتحدث عن اخر جلسات هذه
السنه همم 20 همم 22 ابو ظبي بيخسر حوالي
عشر نقطه مئويه سوق الكويت دعم من البنوك
وبعض الشركات القياديه اجله بين الاسهم
التي تسجل ارتفاعات اسعار النفط ايضا تسجل
ارتفاعات منذ صباح هذا اليوم مع عوده معده
معظم الاسواق الى تداولات ما عدا بطبع
مؤشره هونج كونج والسوق في بريطانيا خلصنا
او محينا كل ارباح صباح هذا اليوم عندنا
ثلاث نقط بتحرك الاسعار اذا امكنوا
القندره على الاسعار مجددا النقطه الاولى
انه الصين اعلنت انه بدا من ثمانيه يناير
لن يكون هناك حجر صحي او كورننتين للسفر
او الوافدين همم الى الصين هذا هيعزز
الطلب على السفر بشكل كبير من قبل
المواطنين الصينيين ومن ثم الطلب ايضا على
نفسه هذه ايضا بادره او اشاره انه
الاقتصاد الصينيه تهيئ لافتتاح همم
اقتصاده بشكل كامل تدريجيا بدا من بدايه
هذه السنه جولدن افتتاح كامل قبل ابريل 20
23 نقطه ثانيه انه روسيا ذكرت انه هيكون
في تخفي اللي همم او انتاجها هيتراجع
بالسبعه في المئه بدايه 20 23 هذا المفروض
ايضا ان يضغط بعد الشيء على العرض فظل
بالطبع استمرار مراقبتنا لاخر مستجدات وضع
سقف سعري على كل ما هو صادرات نفطيه
وغازيه من روسيا النقطه الثالثه ولا ربما
هي الاهم تاتي من الولايات المتحده وهي
الاعاصير التي تضرب الولايات المتحده في
فصل الشتاء
اكيد تضعف الطلب على الاقل على المدى
القسام
ارباح صباح هذا اليوم التي كانت بحدود
الواحد من المئه يتداول دون مستوى 84 9
تداول يعود مره اخرى دون مستوى الثمانيين
الدولار في ظل بالطبع احجام تداولات تعتبر
ضعيفه في عطله اعياد الميلاد اسواق اسيا
صباح هذا اليوم رايناها تغلق على بعض
الايجابيه الذهب يرتفع مع الرغم انه
بنتحدث عن عوده شهيه اخذ المخاطر في السوق
مع مجموعه من ارقام همم او العوامل
الاقتصاديه الايجابيه نرى الدولار يتراجع
مقابل اليورو مقابل الاسترليني الين عند
مستوى ال 132 ايضا
همم 133 17
يتداول عندها اليان في هذه اللحظات في ظل
الاستمرار ضعف الدولار وعوده شهيه اخذ
المخاطر من قبل المستثمرين اذا هذا كان
سامري او تقريبا
الاخبار نحن نعود بعد قليل ببرامج الاسواق
العربيه نحلل كل ما هو مهم لاسواق المنطقه
واسواق العالميه الان عوده اليك فاطمه بس
فيديوهات العربيه بالرياضيات
نعود الى اجواء العواصف والثلوج التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده اظهرت مقاطع فيديو من
مدينه بافلو في نيويورك تغطيها الثلوج
العواصف الثلجيه مشاهدينا ادت الى وفاه
اكثر من 20 شخصا وشلت الحركه في فتره
نهايه الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
نقف مع ابرز الصور ولا لقطات لشهر اغسطس
لهذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في ختام هذه الساعه نذكر بالعناوين
كيف تطالب بمحاسبه موسكو عن جرائم حرب
وكوتيريش يشترط موافقته كافه الاطراف
للوساطه
ايلين ماسك يعلن توفير الانترنت في ايران
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه لفك حصار النظام على
المتظاهرين
جيش كوريا الجنوبيه يتعهد بتطوير قدراته
ويعتذروا عن فشله في اسقاط مسيرات كوريا
الشماليه
رئيس صربيا يعلن حاله التاهب القصوى للجيش
لاستخدام القوه المسلحه بسبب التوترات مع
كسوفو
في امان الله
[موسيقى]